so I'd like to thank the organizers in
particular iron and nickel for having me
here I'll be talking about some
polynomials that I think you know not
actually there is similar to the ones
that Ryan or Donald mentioned in his
talk but these polynomials you know will
be related to general matrices not
necessarily adjacency matrices of graphs
the set up was this thing so if you
recall the this is actually a corollary
of the main theorem that Marcus pin when
she was from approved so this was known
as Weavers conjecture result was the
following so if you have a collection of
vectors in CN whose choir norms are less
than or equal to half and which are
isotropic in the sense then you can
partition them into our blocks so that's
a nearest Rick to each block the maximum
eigen value can be bounded by this
quantity which is strictly which turns
out to be strictly less than 1/4 in this
case for our bigger than or equal to 12
and this resolved the so-called fading
conjecture of Anderson and which in turn
I just solve the cat is in single
problem so and this is the fading
conjecture suppose you have a matrix a
the goal is to find a block partition of
the matrix using diagonal projections
with the following property conjecture
was that for any 0 diagonal contraction
then you can find so my contraction I
mean the spectral normos lives on equal
to 1 so the conjecture was that for any
such 0 diagonal contraction
and for any epsilon less than 1 there is
odd which is universal that doesn't
depend upon the matrix or the dimension
so that when you cut down this matrix
using these diagonal blocks the norm is
less than Epsilon and the point was that
you know if you can show this to be true
for any epsilon and any R since this
constant epsilon an R are independent of
the dimension then this translates to an
infinite dimensional statement and which
was equivalent to the Callison Singapore
so Martha Spearman shrivastava the
result in the previous page it
translates to the following in this
setting so now you let the matrix be
hermitian rather than general because of
this condition the zero riding condition
then you can find these projections with
this required property but with the
maximal eigen value in terms of this in
place of a spectral norm and they also
gave a quantitative estimate the number
of blocks needed scales as 1 divided by
epsilon square so as I mentioned you
know this resolved the charism singer
problem now the remarkable thing is that
well if you want the norms of these
matrices to shrink I mean you I mean if
you took the identity matrix I mean that
whole burg so some condition was needed
now the remarkable thing is that the
only thing that you need is that the
diagonals be 0 now there are easy
examples that show that even in this
theorem if you look at how our scales
with epsilon you cannot expect to do
better than 1 divided by epsilon square
and the estimate in the previous page
and also but if you want some
quantitative estimates not an asymptotic
result now the previous result says that
you can take a number of blocks to be
close
again for this last statement must be
mentioned that again there are simple
examples that show that you cannot take
R to be equal to two two blocks are not
enough it is conceivable that three is
enough but we have been able to prove it
here I'll mention a slightly stronger
result later on in the talk now and if
you recall the difference distinction
between these two theorems first of all
you let the matrix be hermitian and you
only control the largest eigenvalue now
if you wanted to pass from this to that
so I would call this one-sided pairing
of harish emission matrices I would call
this norm painting of general matrices
now using simple linear algebra what you
can see is that I mean you do this four
times you do this construction four
times so both for the real and imaginary
parts of the given matrix and if you put
that together you get the following
result then Anderson's original
conjecture is true but for the number of
blocks now you have to take a product of
pairings so 1 divided by epsilon square
you have to multiply with itself four
times and you get one divided by epsilon
to the power of it but as I said this is
enough for Mac Addison singer problem
but it was like these I was curious you
know can this be improved
now then what kind of improvement could
we expect so that is this before the
resolution of the kerosene singer
problem 25 years ago Buddakan is our
fear assured that if instead of wanting
a partition you just wanted one large
block so they showed that you know you
can get a block of size N times epsilon
square so I mean morally this would
suggest that you know that n divided by
n epsilon square or 1 by epsilon square
blocks might be enough for the Catalan
singer problems and that is a simple
example you know over here you know that
says that you know that that says that
you need at least so the scaling of this
is the example that I mentioned so there
is a simple linear algebra example that
I don't want to spend much time on that
says that you know that o of 1 by
epsilon square blocks are needed so know
this thing you know that remember that
if you wanted to go from one sided
paving to norm paving they had to do you
know we had to solve for bearing
problems in parallel
no more generally they could ask you
know suppose we have a collection of
matrices is the in this case we have
three different matrices you want to
find one block partition that works for
all the matrices simultaneously now here
there's another question you know that
you could ask suppose you have K
matrices you know then how does this you
know what is the dependence on K for the
number of partitions you know that you
need so once again you know this is a
simple example there is a you know there
is a again a simple example the homework
problem that you know that says that you
know if you have K blocks the MSS proof
gives one divided by epsilon to the
power of two K and you know you can play
around with it
the see I mean so at least you know that
for a single matrix you need more than
or equal to one by epsilon square blocks
and you mentioned that you know if you
have K matrices you know one can show
that the number of blocks should scale
linearly with the number of matrices so
if you wanted to get this kind of multi
paling result you know from the paling
result for a single matrix I mean let's
see you know what this I mean can you
tweak the main NSS theorem to get this
dessert so this is one generalization
that was apparently proved independently
by several people that says the
following thing so in the original MSS
result so these matrices AI they're
restricted to be Rank 1 but then it was
observed by several authors that that
condition can be dropped and this is
something that Nick Eden mentioned in
his boot camp talk you get exactly the
same estimate but now you need this
condition you know that if these are
higher rank then again the control that
you get is in terms of the trace and you
know this is not very satisfying and
there is some reason to believe that you
know instead of these trace you should
be able to control it by you know but a
log rank or some such thing but that
currently is still open and the problem
is that you know if you try to apply
this to the multi painting result you
know if you took sums of matrices then
you know that is to be so you would you
know you would want to prove this kind
of result that if you have you know K
different collections of vectors
satisfying this condition again you
would want to find a common partition
that achieves the MSS poke so this is
something that you know that we were
able to prove together with Nikhil so
the lower bound is our following so you
can easily construct these K matrices
you know again with this condition so
that the number of blocks that you need
scales as 1 by epsilon square with
regard to epsilon and linearly with
regard to the number of matrices and
this is the easy thing and a little
while ago we were able to show that you
know together with nickel was able to
show that actually the
you can get a result that matches the
lower bound both with regard to K as -
you know epsilon square and this will
involve you know tweaking the method of
introducing polynomials in a fairly
natural day which I will get to now to
do this you know that so in hindsight no
this is the most obvious thing you know
that we could have done so starting with
a matrix which is hermitian you take any
partition of the index set and you write
down you know the corresponding paving
so these are these P is are now diagonal
projections and you look at the some of
these so this is a diagonal block matrix
then the method of introducing
polynomials you know would immediately
tell us you know try to see if you know
there is some kind of interlacing going
on here so what you do is for every
paving you look at the characteristic
polynomial of this block compression and
you add it up so you look at the
expected characteristic polynomial I
mean first of all I mean is it real root
he'll it turns out that yes you know it
is real rooted and the next thing one
would have to prove is that can you
control with nonzero probability the
largest eigen value of one bearing using
the expected characteristic polynomial
at that again you know can be done and
you know for you know for people who
have ever work with interlacing
polynomials actually these facts you
know should be totally routine to prove
and then the main thing the main part
becomes you know how do you control the
largest root of this expected
characteristic polynomial in this case
the expected characteristic polynomial
you know has a very simple expression so
what it just turns out you know to be
you take a determinantal polynomial so
here this Z the Z is a diagonal matrix
of indeterminates so it's a diagonal n
by n matrix with Z 1 Z 2 Zn on the
diagonal you raising to the power of r
you're looking for art paintings and
then you take a suitable alternated
partial derivative and then after you
take all these
this becomes multi a fine and then you
specialize you said all the diving
variables to be equal to each other and
that is exactly what this by the way
this should be our this is exactly what
this expected characteristic polynomials
and then you know it becomes I mean how
do you bound the maximum group of this
and this is typically done using you
know some kind of barrier argument so
there are two ways of doing it one maybe
you know you can find a combinatorial
interpretation of this now I should
remark that this polynomial that you
have over here this is actually exactly
the polynomial that that that I on
O'Donnell mentioned in his talk so you
can write this in another way so suppose
you have actually the matrices don't
have to be the same so suppose you had a
collection of matrices so what you could
do is you could look at so these are all
matrices in these are all hermitian
matrices so what you could do is you
could look at the characteristic
polynomial of a one
now these D is so these are diagonal
matrices of Plus Ones and minus ones and
then you look at the expected
characteristic polynomial over these are
diagonal plus minus one matrices and
then you take the uniform distribution
on all these matrices and then you
average the characteristic polynomial
which if you might recall is exactly the
expression that Ryan O'Donnell had in
his talk you would like to prove an
upper bound so in his case you know he
was the matrices that he worked with had
additional structure and he was able to
use you know combinatorial arguments to
get a grasp on what the largest root was
but here we will actually have to you
know make some calculations and so these
kinds of things again you know these
things you typically use these barrier
type arguments that are also introduced
by Marcus Payne and Srivastava so now
one thing initially you know that when
you write out this polynomial I should
mention that this polynomial that you
have over here you can also write it out
purely as a univariate polynomial so
what you do is so if you look at the so
this is just the expression of for the
determinant but lacking this term this R
to the power of number of cycles Sigma
is if you take a permutation Sigma you
look at the number of cycles C or Sigma
and then you just tweak the determinants
by adding this term so let me call this
our determinant similarly you can write
down the our characteristic polynomial
using the our determinant then it turns
out that actually this expected
characteristic polynomial is precisely
this I mean this looks like a fairly
concrete object and you know is sometime
you know trying to use this expression
to prove root bounds but unfortunately I
mean they couldn't get it to work
actually it's not not at all obvious you
know by just looking at this expression
that this our characteristic polynomial
has this following property that
whenever you evaluate it at a hermitian
matrix the polynomial is real proof it I
mean this is not at all a parent you
know when you first look at it and
however by the way this real book under
doesn't work for R which is not a
positive integer this thing has been
studied not the polynomial as such but
this expression this so-called or
determinant has been studied you know in
the past this has shown up quite
independently of each other in half a
dozen places so there is a different
normalization that is called the alpha
permanent and so on and so forth and the
one thing that we do know about this our
determinant is that whenever you
evaluate the our determinant at a PSD
matrix then it is positive and the only
values of are so that you know for every
PSD matrix it is positive are exactly
those men are is a integer positive or
negative now this thing that I mentioned
about this expected characteristic
polynomial so here what we are doing is
that we are summing over all pairings
and we are either think of it as put in
a uniform distribution over all pairings
but the entire thing also works in a
slightly more general setting so in the
setting of strong generally measures so
recall that a measure on subsets of n is
called a strongly daily measure if this
generating polynomial is real stable so
these were introduced by Bourjois
Brandon and Liggett in 2008-2009 and it
turns out that instead of just averaging
over all partitions uniformly if you
averaged them with respect to any
strongly Rayleigh distribution then the
same thing works and this actually this
can be read out right off from a result
that Nima mentioned earlier this morning
that you do exactly the same thing so
you look at the expected characteristic
polynomial but with regard to a strongly
Rayleigh distribution then the whole
thing works in method
intelligence in polynomial works you can
this expected characteristic polynomial
is real rooted and actually one can
write down what they expected
characteristic so root bounds are
typically proved using this this barrier
method so the so you look at a log
barrier so it is known that if you have
a real stable polynomial then you define
this thing this generalization of you
know the points that are for univariate
polynomial the points in a bigger than
the max root of the univariate
polynomial so you say that you know that
a a point a is above the roots if it
does not vanish or the positive ortant
based on a then a classical fact that
this thing the set of all points above
in the univariate case is an interval is
a half interval I'm sorry it's a it's a
it's a half infinite interval but in the
real stable case in the multivariate
case it is known that the set is convex
and further that the set when you take
the derivative this set above the root
it can only become larger and the whole
point of the barrier method was to get a
estimate on how by what factor to what
extent this set above the roots
increases in size then you apply a
partial derivative so this is done you
know using this log barrier which is
just the law of the real stable
polynomial and this thing the log
barrier you know it has you know several
nice properties you know it is positive
you know it is decreasing along each you
know when you take the partial
derivative then it is decreasing and
then it is also context using this and
in a way that is so what you would like
to do is you know you would like to get
an estimate on the set of all points
that are above the roots of this
polynomial and sort of you know you run
the machinery and what one gets is the
following statement and so this you know
it just involves you know making a
careful calculation that we did together
with Jonathan leak so it saves the
following thing
so the pictorially this is what it says
so let me do the setting then the real
stable polynomial is of let's say at
most is of degree two in each of the
variables then you're going to have a
set which is you know above the roots
and suppose you have a point that is
above the roots of this polynomial and
what you do is you look at the
univariate restriction in any coordinate
direction then what one does is when you
take the derivative you know these
things move to the left but by what
extent so this theorem would say in the
case then R is equal to two you can move
half me to where the largest book of
this restriction is this again you know
if you make some manipulations you get
an expression of this kind but no
involving the smallest root so this will
be in this in this setting so you would
this would be lambda 1 and this would be
lambda 2 so we get refined estimates one
would actually have to have to say you
know that now you're sort of you know
turning it on its head you know what can
you say about the smallest root of a
univariate restriction or the special
polynomials that we have you know
polynomials of this form determinant of
Z minus a power of the terminal of Z
minus a as far as partial derivatives of
such polynomials then one can get an
estimate in terms of the diagonal
entries of the matrix that we started
off with and if you put it all together
you get the following theorem which was
proved jointly with Jonathan over here
that the largest root of the
characteristic polynomial or the
expected characteristic polynomial can
be bounded by this quantity and in
particular that this result would say
that you know when you have a zero
diagonal hermitian contraction then the
largest root is strictly less than 1 by
universal quantity when R is equal to 4
you know improving the MSS result of
12th
No there is one thing you know that this
thing actually fits into a slightly
larger context so MSS that introduced
you know this notion of the additive
convolution of two polynomials so if you
have to relook at polynomials of degree
D let's say banach you write them as
characteristic polynomials of matrices
and you define the following operation
so you look at the expectation over the
unitary group of the characteristic
polynomial of a plus a random rotation
of P now because of the fact that we
take a random rotation so this is an
expression that only depends upon the
eigen values of a and B or the roots of
P and Q and it's a lovely fact that you
know that this additive convolution is
real vocal further it is very simple you
know by by just this thing that you have
a estimate you know for the largest root
of the convolution Q but indeed you can
prove something stronger and this was
key to the paper on the nemesis for on
nomination graphs so it says that and
this is a so they proved a version of
this when our was a polynomial of the
form X minus alpha times X to the power
of n minus 1 and this generalization was
noted by leek and writer so this is
something that they refer to as a sub
modularity property and this is tight
and this cannot be improved and this
result you know if you iterate this are
x so you get the following thing which
again so this is that Ramanujan bound
showing up now would you I mean now the
thing is you know for these optimal
estimates you know the carelessness in a
problem one would like to hope that you
know some similar result holds from the
multivariate setting I mean there is a
natural candidate for a multivariate
additive convolution which is just this
so more general image this you know for
any multi if you have two multi affine
polynomials P and Q I mean in this case
their determinant will but it doesn't
matter you could write down this
expression
you take the partial of P with respect
to a subset and the pop multiplied by
the partial of Q with respect to the
complementary subset and you add it up
this operation preserves real stability
if you start off if p and q are real
stable to begin with then this
polynomial will also be real stable and
you know everything you know that we
could we would want to prove you know
would follow if this kind of sub
modularity that which i mentioned in a
previous slide this one if this kind of
sub model are some modularity but true
in this setting as well and but
unfortunately you know that thing is not
true and i don't think we really
understand you know why this is not true
and understanding why this is not true
and whether this can be fixed you know
would be a really nice so then one can
prove something Beeker you know which is
I which can actually be read out you
know from the estimate that I'd given a
few slides previously but you know that
we would like to remove this you know
they will just like to keep this term
but that doesn't seem to be true no all
of this thing you know that another way
of approaching this you know would be by
looking at this you know this
fundamental operation that it is known
that when you start off with a real
stable polynomial and you remove all
terms that contain powers or variables
so you project it down to the multi a
fine part that preserves real stability
this is a result of Borgia and Brandon
and you know one can write down you know
all the polynomials know that we looked
at over the previous slide they're using
this multi a fine part operator and so
really I mean everything boils down to
once we start over the real stable
polynomial about which you know we know
what the roots look like then can you
get tight estimates for the in this case
a hyperbola silicon of the multi a fine
part of P and the point I would like to
make is that you know the natural
conjecture that one would come up with
is not true it's not clear you know what
the correct analog should be now this
thing what one can do is you know one
can prove you know some the
results so for instance you know if you
have to real stable polynomials and you
apply the second real stable polynomial
as a differential operator onto the
first then the one consequence of this
theorem of lignans so far would be that
you know this polynomial is also real
stable so one can use these log barrier
techniques to get a handle on the
location of the roots so using some
combinatorics so one can write down you
know this operator in a slightly
different form and using this you know
one can prove you know the following
result that you know that using you know
the log barrier techniques you know one
can get estimates for what points lie
above the roots of this convolution
but unfortunately once again you know
this only gives you that the estimates
up to a row of one factor and you know
one can sort of tweak this and you know
make it more general but what you get is
unlikely to be tight but going back to
multi paving so they have a handle on
you know how to prove estimates for the
largest root of the our characteristic
polynomial and so on and so forth so
this all that works for a single matrix
but what if you have a collection of
matrices now here if you'd like to make
the method of introducing polynomials
book so you would like you want one
painting to work for all of them so what
one would do is you know one could take
the characteristic polynomial of this
you fix a painting and you multiply the
characteristic polynomials but then in
that case the method of interlacing
polynomials does not work because the
key thing is that in all applications
you know somehow the polynomials that
you work with have to be written as
specializations of suitable multi affine
polynomials so here so we introduced
this thing together with nickel that is
this object called mixed determinant
which again has shown up now in there
what the mixed determinant is if you
have a collection of matrices you look
at them so you take a partition of the
base set and you multiply the
restrictions the block restrictions of
these different
versus relative to these elements in the
partition this object is called a mixed
determinant and it has you know I mean
if all the a is a positive semi definite
that this is also part then this is
positive and so on and so and again you
cook up a poly a univariate polynomial
using this this normalization factor is
to ensure that when all the matrices are
the same then what you get is exactly
the K characteristic for our
characteristic polynomial and the dis in
hand
you know the entire interlacing
machinery books but before that you
would actually like to say that you know
that this the single polynomial you know
that you have written down that when you
have a couple of matrices write down the
single polynomial that somehow you know
you you can use it to control the
eigenvalues of the max eigen values of
all the matrices you know in the tuple
and it turns out that that is indeed the
case you know by a fairly
straightforward the convexity argument
no one can show that the single
polynomial controls the max root of all
the scale polynomials up to a factor of
K which again which is asymptotically
tight you can do better than that and
with this in hand you know once you can
make the method of interlacing
polynomials work for this polynomial you
know you can relate it back to the
individual matrices so
now you have this rootbound you know
that I had mentioned that you know for a
single when this thing one of the you
know you can the estimates that you know
the MSS prove you know can be used to
show that you know for a single matrix
the our character is fallen max route of
the order 1 by root R but then it also
works for the tuple of matrices so when
you have a permission to 'pl where every
matrix is a zero diving infraction then
you have an estimate on the largest root
of this mixed determinant of polynomial
and the factor that you get is is of the
order of 1 by root K and this thing so
this is how we make the method of
introducing polynomials work so given a
partition and a tuple so we write down
this associated polynomial and for these
collections of polynomials you can use
interlacing arguments so you can relate
you know the mixed determinant
polynomial restricted to one partition
using the expected characteristic
polynomial and now there are each a has
K matrices there are you take each the
you tape is tuple are time so you have a
total of are times K matrices and so
this is the estimate that one gets and
putting it all together one gets the
following theorem that when you have a
collection of 0 driving emissions then
there exists a painting a common
painting a painting that works for all
of them with the right asymptotic
dependence this thing that there is mean
there was some interest you know in this
problem this thing so if you are sorry
you specialize this to a single to if
you go back to Anderson's original
conjecture that says that yes indeed you
know you do get the right asymptotic
dependence there was some interest in
this problem members of this question
that Johnson was a von Scheck man had
looked at is a very basic question and
linear algebra it's this the following
thing that if you have a zero trace
matrix we can write it as a commutator
and then you would like to find a
commutator decomposition
whose norm is
as small as possible and it is I mean I
you know I think that you know that one
should be able to do it with a constant
that does not depend on the dimension in
a dimension independent constant but
using this thing so they had used a
weaker version of the result that I
mentioned that to show this that this
constant can be taken as drawings slower
than any polynomial in n but then using
our theorem we've been able to improve
it to this to something some exponential
now there are a couple of so this thing
I think I'm going to end early there are
a couple of things a couple of curious
questions know that I'd like to pose and
you know solicit any insights that you
might have so recall that this was a
definition you know this our determinant
so this thing there are some hardness
results about the our determinant you
know that are known so in terms of the
cut polynomial so mertens and more you
know showed that you know when this is
for odd that is a integer so this thing
you know that calculating the are
determined is hard because you can
relate it you know to evaluating the TEC
polynomials of certain associated the
planar draws for which a lot is known so
it is known that the touch column is /p
hard to evaluate even for planar graphs
unless the parameters x and y lie in a
very very specific domain and further
approximation schemes it is known that
is also hard to approximate in certain
regimes but i mean but the point is not
just because you know this quantity is
hard to evaluate it does not necessarily
mean that you know that the back slope
of the associated polynomial is hot to
approximate or evaluate or some such
things so there are these curious things
you know that numerical simulations you
know seem to show up that this somehow
this this polynomial seems to become
very well behaved you know for i
mentioned that you know for our that is
a positive integer this is always real
rooted for any hermitian but if all is
sufficiently large whether or not it is
an integer
somehow this polynomial all this
to be real broken and another very
curious question you know that came up
is the following thing so so here this
this quantity that we have over here so
this is a class function or the
symmetric group now for any class
function of the symmetric group in a one
who'll write down this expression and
write up associated polynomial and you
know something I've been wondering about
you know for quite some time now what
are the class functions that have the
following property that you know that
this polynomial is a real rooted for
every hermitian and I think that you
know these are the only ones but this is
something that you know that you are not
been able to prove which is a basic and
fundamental question and be really
curious you know the answer to
[Applause]
[Applause]